greetings and welcome to the National
Press Club I'm Eric Parkinson I'm
president and publisher of Hanover house
40 years ago America's innocence was
shattered by four gunshots in Dallas and
the assassination of President John
Fitzgerald Kennedy while the nation
grieved a transition of power occurred
that had been in the works for over two
years
Vice President Lyndon Baines Johnson
seceded JFK to the position of president
and the course of history was forever
changed the subsequent investigation
into the assassination resulted in the
infamous Warren Commission report and
the Lone Gunmen theory that most
Americans believed to be so absurd that
over 80 percent believed that a much
larger plan was involved that has since
been proven true new evidence has been
released it clearly shows the direct
involvement of LBJ and his advisors in
the assassination and subsequent
cover-up and insider to the LBJ team has
released some of this evidence in a new
book but more proof of what really
happened in 1963 is still being withheld
and should be released for public review
and discussion in the words of John
Fitzgerald Kennedy himself the great
enemy of the truth is very often not the
lie deliberate contrived and dishonest
but the myth persistent persuasive and
unrealistic after 40 years the American
public has tired of the myth of the
Warren Commission report and demands to
know the truth it is my pleasure to
introduce a brave man who knows the
truth as a true insider to the LBJ team
his knowledge and insight will serve as
a springboard to re-examine the JFK
assassination case and the requests that
are being made to the Senate Judiciary
Committee the Department of Justice and
the National Archives to release sealed
documents that are relevant in this
matter some of the evidence is presented
in the book blood money and power
how LBJ killed JFK to discuss his book
and the the new evidence in today's call
for action I'm very proud to bring you
author and attorney Barr McClellan
thank you Eric and ladies and gentlemen
good afternoon thank you for being here
we are here because of the book I wrote
blood money and power
how LBJ killed JFK I was fortunate to be
helped by about 20 very qualified
researchers but the book is my
responsibility and I accept that of
course the book is like many books it
has a beginning a middle and an end a
cover but it's different authors are
instructed by many other writers to
write from their experience and of
course I could write this book from my
experience but there's more to it it
deals with the real world with what's
going on even today and so it's not a
book of deep history of something that
happened a long time ago it's a book of
things going on right now
and it's a book about the assassination
of John Kennedy which is one of the most
emotional issues I think that the
American people have to struggle with
because of that there's been a lot of a
lot of books written a lot of things
said and I have tried in my book to
avoid as much as possible anything I
might tell you what I've tried to do is
focus on what I call the hard evidence
in fact in the book you could take out
the hard evidence the exhibits
themselves with the explanations of what
each one represents and have the heart
of the story we have today placed some
of these key exhibits on the wall now
there are a total of 68 exhibits but the
first one is the mastermind behind the
assassination that man is Edward Clark
and he is at the top left
Edie Clark was recognized as early as
1949 as the boss of Texas he had a
system for cutting deals with judges and
legislatures where they would agree with
him and do what he said and he was very
effective about it it's what what came
to be known as Bubba justice and he was
good and he was the man that was called
on by
Johnson but let me turn you to the next
exhibit which is his war record a lot of
people don't know about these things
and they wouldn't be public knowledge
except for the fact that he left all of
his personal records to one of his
universities and they weren't vacuumed
typically these personal records are
very carefully gone through by lawyers
and what just might be bad is thrown out
well we found several in there and the
librarian at first didn't want to
release him but they did and the second
document up there behind beside him is
his army record at a time when the war
was going very badly for the United
States we were barely holding on in
Guadalcanal and we just landed in North
Africa he was stealing money from the
quartermaster in Florida he was kicked
out of the army with about a summary a
kick-out as you can do they even bought
his wife in to make sure that there was
never a claim for any benefits for being
a veteran this was never known this was
course was kept quiet but it a measure
of the man and the capability of what he
could do and he did the next picture the
next of exhibit up there the handwritten
note is written by Edward Clark and this
was written shortly after the famous or
infamous 1948 stolen election when
Lyndon Johnson with one of my law
partners named Don Thomas down there
stuffing the ballot box getting two
hundred and two extra votes mostly dead
people shortly after that financial
problems arose and the letter
handwritten by Edward Clarke is to the
effect that we have to take care of this
man for good
and we have financial problems and we
have to make some special arrangements
calling the notes and it's a dangerous
thing to do in effect the next letter is
the typewritten letter back on the top
right there that's from Lyndon Johnson
the next day saying I know the risk
you're taking and we appreciate what
you're doing and we will see that you
are protected in effect at an early time
here they've laid out a conspiracy this
is that these are the basic elements of
a conspiracy to control things cover up
things to commit crimes
the next picture the next photo on the
second row on the left there is a letter
from Lyndon Johnson in 1960 in which he
expresses his great esteem for Edward
Clark he says he knows there is no man
to whom he's more indebted and he knows
that everything's been possible through
what Edward Clark has been able to do
what we have here is an acknowledgment
in 1960 of the power Clark had over
Johnson during these years there's
something else about it Clark operated
back in Texas and the national media
didn't pick up a lot of this information
and the Texas media was about the good
old boys just like the Democratic Party
was back in those days so this type of
information was just not generally known
and that's what I'm bringing out here
the next is a composite and this was
made in 1961 shortly after our 1960
letter here the composite was of a man
who was involved somehow they weren't
sure at the time when they made the
composite in the murder of a Department
of Agriculture official who was
investigating some schemes that Johnson
had been involved in the composite was
released and I've put up there next to
it a picture of Mac Wallace and Mac
Wallace is the key hit man we've been
able to identify Mac Wallace was
involved with Johnson from early on you
know he went to school in Austin Texas
in 1951 he killed a man to help a
scandal from being made public he was he
killed this man Doug Kinser who was
involved in a sex circle with Lyndon
Johnson's sister Josefa and Kinser had
been wanting some money from the federal
government at the time this was right
after the 48 election and everybody in
the state was getting ready to run
against Lyndon Johnson he could not take
any scandal and it was brewing in a very
bad way Doug Kendra was killed to keep
it quiet Mac Wallace was the man who did
the job when he was arrested he admitted
he was working for Johnson and nothing
else was ever
heard of it he was tried convicted the
jury split they wanted to give him the
death penalty or life a life sentence he
was being tried by one of Edward Clark's
lawyers the lawyer took the case gave
him a five-year sentence and suspended
it
Wallace walked away a free man then
Wallace appears again and there's his
picture and you can compare it to the
composite and my point is these exhibits
speak for themselves those two men I
mean the composite and the man are one
in the same what really brings it home
is the next document up which is the one
the middle right there that's an
indictment by a grand jury in Texas and
it was an indictment action indictment
action for the murder of Henry Marshall
who was shot by Mac Wallace on june 3 of
1961 the indictment however was not
returned until 1984 and the indictment
itself reads the three persons
responsible are now deceased which means
they couldn't indict him but they were
named as Mac Wallace cliff Carter and
Lyndon Johnson so you have a picture
here in 1961 of what is going to
motivate Johnson to do what he does
the next picture the bottom left one is
of D H Byrd and he was a member of Big
Oil in up in Dallas Big Oil plays a big
role in this they were key supporters of
Johnson Johnson during his Senate years
was literally the lobbyist for the oil
industry on the floor of the Senate and
D H Byrd is the man who owned the Texas
Book School Book Depository so we're
bringing all of this down to these final
two pictures middle two pictures the one
the second one from the left is a photo
of the Warren Commission by the Warren
Commission of the fingerprints that were
recovered by the Warren Commission at
the sniper's nest and on the sixth floor
of the depository when I started my
research to finish the book up I went to
to the Warren Commission record records
I knew Johnson was involved I had to see
what proof
put together and there were a bunch of
fingerprints that were recovered by the
Warren Commission that were not
identified I knew Mike Wallace had had a
print card from his murder in 1951 and
we got those two together the archives
provided the fingerprints that were
recovered from the picture they're the
sniper's nest and we had the print card
we took them as a blind submission to a
highly qualified latent print examiner
in Austin Texas name of Nathan Darby and
Nathan helped Kodak develop a
fingerprint system and he set up the
fingerprint identification system for
the Philippines he agreed to take it
blind we did that because people get so
emotional about the assassination and
either have a fixed opinion or just
can't really look at something
objectively that we did it that way and
he agreed and he found the match at that
point we knew we had the case we needed
I've been building up to with these
exhibits - what else was going on and
there are more but we had the heart of
the case and it's again it's not what I
can tell you it's what these exhibits
say and that put the lid on the case and
I was able to go with the book speak
with Eric and we've had a good
relationship ever since I have to add
but the book could be finished but there
is another step in it you need to see
and that's the last exhibit it comes
back to Edward Clark where the cover-up
becomes a part of the crime this letter
was written by Leon Jaworski - the
attorney for Jack Ruby who happened to
be a very dear friend of Edward Clark's
where they're telling Tana he'll don't
get Ruby excited keeping quiet in effect
Muslim so the cover-up becomes complete
the crime becomes complete I've been
able to lay out through these hard
exhibits which again is not anything I
have to tell you these are all public
records this is how it happened and how
it falls together now that's just like I
say a good part of the book of all the
exhibits the story itself to really be
told
to be brought out to avoid theory and to
deal with hard exhibits I have to go
back in deep into Texas history and we
do that to show how in early Texas
history at a time when Johnson and Clark
were growing up lynchings were common
people carried pistols all the time and
they were involved in these things then
to get to their childhood they're
growing up here as you can see how that
violence remained a part of their lives
Johnson had he been a juvenile today
would be a delinquent under today's
standards probably the most brutal
things he did and this is this is well
known was killed a mule it sounds like a
simple thing but back in those days and
even today you don't go around killing
domesticated animals and he was mean he
stayed the book then goes into how these
men came together in Austin how they
became best of friends because Johnson's
first election depended on Edward Clark
going to the governor and getting the
governor to enlist the state employees
to vote for Edward vote for Lyndon
Johnson the point there was Lyndon
didn't even get a majority then he
barely had 30 percent he and it was a
plurality type election but their
relationship started then and continued
all through Johnson's career the next
part of the book turns on the real
beginning of the conspiracy and the
conspiracy really begins with the 1948
election when Don Thomas who was Lyndon
Johnson's business attorney and one of
the two men he worked most closely with
with the law firm went down to Alice
Texas and stuffed the ballot box I've
mentioned that but that was again a part
of getting this relationship as solid as
it was so and of course Clarke plays
another important role in that in that
particular election one that have known
of the state Democratic Committee
approves the candidates Johnson wins by
one vote and that one vote was Edward
Clark so the conspiracy can really be
traced to these early years and you can
see how these men still had
this willingness to do anything that
crime was was okay the law really meant
nothing and as I mentioned Clark had
such a control on the judges his deal
was very simple with them if it's a
closed case you rule for me I get to
call it a closed case if I call for you
you talked to me and he made sure they
stayed happy by giving them gifts poker
winnings money to family money to
friends he had him wrapped well I was so
important for all of Texas's this was in
Austin and at the time most of your
state laws were enforced only in Travis
County so Clark had a real stranglehold
on a state that way to make his Texas
justice Bubba justice work and he did
what I've also been able to bring in is
what else started about this time and
that's the money machine Johnson was
getting ready to run for re-election and
he had to be so good no one run against
him and he was successful and he raised
so much money that they had to run it
through Brazos 10th Street corporation
now this begins the money trail which I
don't think has ever been covered in any
other review regarding the assassination
he brings in so much money that they can
use it to buy back his ranch put money
in banks buy land in other words he got
very wealthy through the Texas election
and political process this brings us
down to the conspiracy itself and one
thing the Warren Commission really
overlooked was motivation I think any
criminal investigator will tell you one
of the first things you do is look at
who stood to gain they almost refused to
look at that when they were formed up
two of the men came in two members of
the Commission came in and said first of
all lone nuts do it all the time I cut
off a conspiracy thinking the second
thing was we're not a banana republic I
bring out in the book how we were a
banana republic because Lyndon Johnson
learned how to be one through George
Parr down in the Texas Valley we have
then this motivation
I laid some of this out so far but the
big motivations Johnson had were twofold
when he was running the Senate by 1960
he was recognized as the de facto
President of the United States and yet
he has to step aside and let this young
upstart named John Kennedy who did not
do any work in the Senate become
president the flip side was the murder
of Henry Marshall happened during
Kennedy's inaugural week Johnson met
with Billy Sol Estes who was a promoter
in agriculture back in Texas and they
knew they had to hush Henry Marshall
they wanted to talk to him and see if
they could persuade him and they sent
Mac Wallace in to do the job
he went to see him at his ranch
Marshalls ranch on June 3 of 1961 they
couldn't do anything the fight ensued
he's knocked out he's they tried ball
his first tries to kill him with carbon
monoxide poisoning and shoots him five
times with a bolt-action rifle the next
day under the gun at the Clark justice
system the Jaypee rules a suicide well
no one really bought that and this is
when Johnson's troubles really started
so not only did he have this unlimited
ambition to be President to get all the
power he could he had this real fear of
going to the jailhouse the way he had
put it when he was de facto president he
was in the mansion when he became vice
president he became out house and I add
to it that he was really afraid of being
in the jailhouse so you put this man
together and you see everything is there
all the ingredients are there for him to
make a decision that he's got to move up
or he's got to move out and if he moves
out he's indicted so what happens is and
we see this from documents that he gave
at Clark as he provided ed Clark the
policy manual the Secret Service policy
manual for the protection of the
president along he was vice president in
effect laying out the game plan for how
to conduct the assassination itself
Clark took on the job and he took his
time it's not an easy thing to
gather everything together that he
needed to gather together what he did do
was make sure that some people would
take care of his fees in effect he
wanted to be paid and he went to
Murchison in Dallas to get a commitment
there I found out about this through
work I was doing with another key member
of Big Oil in Dallas representing them
and getting higher natural gas prices we
brought a case that ended up blowing the
lid off gas regulation and in the course
of it I learned how Murchison had been
approached by Clark and Murchison agrees
to support Clark he continues to support
him during the presidency and after the
presidency but this puts all the
ingredients into place with Mac Wallace
being called upon again once again to do
the job and we know how he operated
there was a witness who came forward Loy
factor was his name and a book came out
on him at the same time I was completing
my fingerprint research this was all
independent research but Loy factor is
brought in by Mike Wallace he's
recruited at Sam Rayburn's funeral and
he is later tested to see if he can
shoot and he states that he was there at
Dealey Plaza with Mac Wallace on the day
the assassination we also know how
Oswald came into the picture he had come
back from Russia and Soviet Union at the
time and had been introduced to Russian
expatriates in Dallas two of those
people good friends of Clark and let him
know about this outsider this unhappy
person who was willing to do anything
I also learned about him through Sam
Balan who was a client of mine and he
was an oil geologist who met Sam at Lee
Harvey Oswald and tried to get him a job
and he Sam confirmed to me later that
the connections were there that Sam that
Lee Harvey Oswald was brought into the
picture that way we have more just like
Roy factor was tested by Wallace Oswald
was tested by seeing if he could shoot
Edwin Walker retired general who had
been retired for being critical
of John Kennedy or of the Democratic
policies at the time and he was there
helping Oswald carry off the shot after
the assassination we know that Oswald
was there from the rifles testing that
was done by the Dallas Police Department
and this came out through the court of
inquiry so all the stage is set now for
the assassination itself and the crime
scene analysis that we were able to do
and I say we these researchers I was
working with really puts puts it all
together there were four people involved
Oswald shot and he was a patsy
Wallace was there and he got one shot in
we had a missed shot and we had a guy on
us over on the grassy knoll area in the
stockade there's a stockade fence there
going to the triple underpass and he
fired the fatal shot we've reconstructed
this from the crime scene and we know
two very important things one is how did
Wallace get away and it became apparent
he got away by getting taking the same
route Oswald did only he moved quicker
and faster he knew he had to get out
under cover of the shock and he did
there was another man with him who
helped him and made sure that the
stairwell was open we know they were
there because there were two men stopped
by the Dallas Police Department
immediately after the shooting and he
said they told me they were Secret
Service agents and the badges that
anyone who claimed to be a Secret
Service agent could only have come
through the vice president similarly a
Dallas police officer stopped a man over
by the pergola there on the grassy knoll
area in the parking lot he too said he
was Secret Service and this was the
shooter and we have been able to
identify him yet we've named him jr. for
now we don't have the kind of proof we
have with Mike Wallace of eyewitnesses
and and the confessions and fingerprints
the Warren Commission knew those three
men had been spotted by the Dallas
Police Department
and the Warren Commission said there
were no Secret Service agents on the
ground at the time they didn't do
anything else about it they seemingly by
saying there were no Secret Service
agents there the men who told the Dallas
Police Department they were Secret
Service agents weren't there but we know
they were there it was one other aspect
of the Warren Commission study that was
not looked into so we have a complete
picture of how the crime was conducted
from a crime scene investigation itself
the shooting occurred and the next step
was what I put in the title called run
and that title starts immediately at
that chapter starts immediately after
the shooting with the men on the run and
it continues until the cover-up is
complete until we get to that last
exhibit over there where Ruby is told
and keep it quiet I haven't completed
all the work bringing Ruby into it we've
had some some recent news that he may
have been communicating with Johnson as
early as 1962 before the assassination
but mainly we know that he would been
recruited through Murchison and
organized crime through what was known
as the red man's club in Dallas other
researchers have come up this close
we've got Ruby into the picture he had
to be brought in because Oswald was
supposed to die in a blaze of glory and
if you follow the the Warren Report
you'll see how that did happen he didn't
have his pistol but he went to the
boarding house got it first police
officer he saw his shot he was officer
Tippit and when he gets to the Texas
theater to try and hide he tries to
shoot it out and the Dallas Police
Department one officer was able to put
his hand on the gun before it could be
fired so we got a problem
Oswald is still around the cover-up is
not the cover-up as in danger so what we
and what you hear Oswald say is I'm a
patsy now there's some people who say
there was another Oswald or oswald one
there but if this man they have says
he's a patsy he's involved if he's
innocent he says he's innocent other
evidence of course puts him there the
rifle the fingerprints he was there he
was new
the shooting so we've got this problem
and that's where ruby comes in and ruby
is recruited to kill and indeed does
killed Oswald and one of the more
dramatic television scenes I think we've
ever seen Ruby then becomes the problem
and that's where the letter to Tana hill
Ruby's letter Ruby's attorney becomes
necessary ruby has to be silenced and he
is the story is complete the cover-up is
done the Warren Commission issuses
report everything is over except for a
lot of independent researchers who did
their best looking from the outside in
without the power of subpoena or
investigation that the Department of
Justice has and they were able to keep
it alive and bring together so much of
the evidence that we now have the unique
thing I can bring in is insider
information as his lawyer I went with
the law firm in 1966 and immediately did
work for Johnson was rewarded with my
own television program the law and you
which broadcast just before the NFL game
of the week which was a very good spot
for television people and for me I
worked with him on other items on other
projects too but mostly I worked very
closely with Ed Clark and with Don
Thomas I was at Clark's personal
attorney when he tries to finish out his
fee requirements we make an application
for a bonus well working with Murchison
and Clark ends up after five years of
working on it with two million dollars
cold cash after taxes I can bring these
things out because after I left the law
firm I had an ethical dispute with them
and left after I left when we got to
litigation I was getting nowhere in the
courthouse and so I just put out what I
knew this was in 1984 put in an
affidavit it was filed in courts in
Texas the DA knew about it the story in
effect was out couldn't do anything with
it at the time and later after Clark
passes on
I can get things cleared up with the
courthouse everything's been dismissed
there and take the next step which is
this research of finding the
fingerprints we present it well let me
stop being I mentioned something about
this being dealing with a real world
when we had the fingerprints and I guess
this was the most emotional experience I
had in the course of this whole event
this whole book I knew we had to do one
thing and that's what the Kennedy family
know so we had this package together
that was going to be taken to the
authorities again it's it's still an
open case but the first thing I had to
do was send a letter to the senator
Kennedy and let him at least know that
this was coming out and I just it's very
emotional thing that and I didn't expect
an answer it was a courtesy more than
anything we've since got an indication
we may have someone willing to say
something on that score but for right
now I had completed it we presented it
to the assassination records Review
Board they were closing their doors at
the time we presented it in the Senate
house trying to get them to do something
they were reluctant to do anything then
the book was written over the next five
years it takes time to write a book edit
it fact check it at all and now it's out
the book has more than just a book again
we're dealing with the real world it
calls for some reforms that we need in
our system of government Eric mentioned
getting the records that are still with
hell back out again and this is
important and we have some interest in
getting this done we're going to keep
pushing on it there are a number of
researchers meeting across the country
Dallas Pittsburgh - in Dallas one in
Pittsburgh and that pushes on through
them also we think we can get these
records released my biggest push is to
get the legal records released all the
work Clark did for Johnsons was kept in
what I call the penthouse files the
firm's records were kept up in the top
penthouse of the building we were in
behind lock and key and wall and another
lock and if those could be released what
I'm able to bring to you in the book
we'll be brought out to the public
Johnson when he dedicated the LBJ
library said he wanted everything out so
what we need to do is enlist the help of
the archives who have control of the LBJ
library to say this is what Johnson
wanted give us those records he's waive
the privilege you'll find out what I'm
telling you from those records now
that's the book we've had a lot of
things happen in the course of preparing
the book some people don't want it out
we've had some efforts to censor it some
people who believe there was a lone nut
who fired a silver bullet say in effect
burned the book but we've gotten a great
deal of good support from a lot of
people and of course moving ahead with
it that pretty well covers the story of
the book and brings us down to the
present we are looking for more action
it's been a real experience for me the
thing I found I guess most revealing has
been to have this book in my hands and
realize just how valuable the book
really is not just this book any book
I've always enjoyed books did a lot of
writing as a lawyer I did it as the
authors tell you go out and get a lot of
experience and I was able to write it
but a book for our friends on book notes
is a wonderful thing and it was again an
emotional experience having it completed
that's mainly what I have I guess as my
son says if anyone has any questions let
me let me stop with just one second I'm
very pleased to have my wife with me
today - Cecile williams has joined me
and she's been very helpful with the
book and on questions I've been asked to
ask anyone with a question to please
step up to the mic
really just questions I'm here at
Grizelda National Press Club two
questions two-part question number one I
came in a bit late
was this the that was the book the
foundation upon which this History
Channel broadcast last night was based
no it was not the History Channel was
recorded while the book was being
written but it was before the book was
completed you LBJ's so-called mistress
as she was identified last night on that
program I know I didn't but researchers
I worked with have talked to her and
have interviewed her and she's confirmed
the essential thrust of your book yes
she has now she passed on though in June
last year but she put a book out before
she died
Texas in the morning and it is available
one last question
lots of conspiracy theories out there
you obviously come with a good degree of
credibility but what you say to people
that question your credibility and say
this is just it's wacko as Nellie
Connolly implied the other day when she
was at a book fair in Austin or you did
raise another subject there but first
thing is that's why I put these hard
evidence together these exhibits that
you can't really quarrel with you don't
have to believe a word I say but if you
look at those exhibits and most of them
are new the picture is complete the best
I can do is connect the dots and explain
what was going on thank you you
mentioned you sent this to your findings
to Senator Kennedy but then you stopped
short about what his response was or
what you think it will be what was his
response when you sent this to him and
what have you heard from the Kennedys
about this well we in the second
question it says set question sit down
you have two powerful sons here in
Washington and I'm wondering what they
think about it and what their reaction
is to it let me see if I can do it first
question second question here the
Kennedys I knew from their past practice
would not likely say anything so I
really didn't expect a response but I
felt that what we had deserved the
courtesy of being brought to their
attention and we did do that
we have an indication from a person
claiming to be a member of the family
that the description in the book of what
happened in Dallas and at Parkland
Hospital and on the airplane is accurate
we're still working on that but my point
there is is we're dealing with something
here in the real world and we're getting
responses as we say in the book people
have answers and they don't even know
the questions and we're getting that
feedback now and it's it's proving to be
a very interesting life in the real
world sort of book my sons knew about
the knew that I was working on a book
and have known about it for several
years because the book has been in the
works for that long they have not
participated any of the research or any
of the writing and they did know when we
made the fingerprint match and the other
evidence was presented to the
assassinations Records Review Board but
they didn't participate in any way shape
or form again it's my responsibility and
I'm putting it out under my signature
they did get the book once it was
published I've mailed it to them and I
will be with them over the weekend and
I'm sure it will have a little bit to
talk about what I did find is their
wives were more interested in the book
than they were even I think they're
trying to figure out what their father
is like and maybe learn about them any
other questions
is there anything more about Lee Harvey
Oswald or Jack Ruby that we should know
that most people don't know I think the
big thing on Lee Harvey Oswald was how
he had these important connections with
Clark this has not been known before
mainly came through Big Oil Sam Balan
was one person who who I related
represented it could confirm a lot of
this and Sam Balan was a witness at the
at the Warren Commission about Ruby you
need to know that his lawyer was named
by Clark was a very close friend and the
exhibit on the wall here shows how Clark
could call upon Tannehill to control
Ruby and in fact keeping muzzled so this
connection into what I call the Texas
justice or Bubba justice system exists
with both Oswald and Ruby Oh as far as
the divorce case with Oswald with his
his widow I mean is that significant as
far as the representation there the
attorney no no that's not at all and out
there I mean could you raise an
important little point here that I need
to mention the book is not the Warren
Commission report I don't have any 26
extra volumes I try and here to give you
an overview there's a lot more involved
some of its pretty tangential and not
really relevant to the heart of the case
but which I tried to bring out and a lot
that's to the heart of the case is
assumed to be knowledge on the part of
the reader I'm working on another book
to try and bring out some of the points
you're just making how this Texas
justice system up close couldn't be as
corrupt as it was
I have two questions first of all what
are the documents that you would like to
see release and what makes you think
that those documents exist and who would
be releasing them and second of all what
experience have you had you mentioned
that there's been some media censorship
and I know that you were booked and
announced for Good Morning America and
canceled this last minute and
subsequently ABC announced that they had
created an animated special with the
magic bullet and I'm just wondering if
if you can comment on the obstacles
you've encountered with getting press
coverage on on your book
well the obstacles have been from from
many directions really we've been
successful in getting programs booked
and then once we announce them we find
them cancelled Eric mentioned the good
mornings Good Morning America setting
that setting was announced confirmed
posted on their web page and ready to go
when they got word apparently from above
to cancel it
censorship is what we're dealing with
here I'm afraid and we need to get
around that I've also heard it from some
writers in the field Gerald Posner says
don't buy the book in effect saying burn
it but I don't know what he's afraid of
I don't know what censorship has to do
with getting this book out and bringing
out these facts that are not available
in any other way which gets to the first
part of your question there are a lot of
documents apparently still out there
the assassination records Review Board
was successful in getting a good bit out
but the president's foreign policy
intelligence board didn't turn its
reports over the Department of Justice
and FBI held back records and the CIA
still hasn't answered some other key
questions those we know of for sure and
the Warren Commission itself had about I
think it's 300 cubic feet of documents
that it suppressed when it issued its
report now those supposedly have been
but they've been redacted which means
the key information has been crossed out
and you really don't have anything there
either so the government itself has a
vast amount but I say vast because there
is so much vast documents already but
there is a lot out there still that we
need and the strange thing is the
government sitting over on the hill is
ordered the government sitting down
Pennsylvania Avenue here to turn these
documents over and the government itself
cannot get the government to release
these documents so we're calling on the
government to to do something and again
we're not the only ones a number of
other people are there's a lot out there
and we really need to bring it in and
again I'll fall back on the lawyers
records if we get those you get the
picture any other questions
worse for you to write this book I think
when it was always said and done I had
an agent who told me it would be a great
story but it is a good story and I do
want to tell it and I've lived it I
think it's very important and I try and
bring this out in the book where out
what I'm really trying to do here is
more is involved here than may appear on
his face the idea that a vice president
would kill a president is foreign to the
thinking of many Americans in New York I
get asked the question how could a vice
president think that way I tell him well
John here's what happened
New York had a vice president in 1800
name of Aaron Burr and he killed and he
tried to take over the country and set
up his own country tried to do it
Aaron Berger grew out of this
Revolutionary War where killing was okay
violence was an accepted way of life
dueling was okay
foot forward about 150 years and you
have a man of that same mentality that
violence is okay and you see it in
Lyndon Johnson you see it in Edward
Clark so they're willing to go ahead
with it and these things are important
to to approach I think I really ended up
as I was finishing the book trying to
understand it myself and
and come to some kind of an
understanding that made sense and I
found one thing fact in fiction books
have a lot in common good fiction is
good fact and good fact makes good
fiction what we're really dealing with
here though is power and how it corrupts
and some of the great novels and plays
in history have addressed this question
and the one out that came to my mind I
put it in the book here is Hamlet where
he knows what has happened his father
the King's been killed and his uncle had
taken open and he knew he had to do
something for that and he the question
he posed himself was to be or not to be
and people have wondered what he was
really meaning I think when you see the
end of the play you see what he was
talking about because the kingdom was
over he was dead and it was really an
awesome step that he was trying to
consider and it did cause him pause I
think we have the same thing now here
and we just have got to face up to what
happened they sit on these facts more
facts like I've been able to put on the
wall here and get an answer yes a lot of
the the men yeah were that that that we
know from this time period I mean they
all really aspired to power I mean I've
heard accusations that Richard Nixon
knew much more than you know what has
generally been known and I'm John
Connally you know obviously was
seriously contending for president and
Bobby Kennedy did that are there
connections there that I mean as far as
with aspirations of these men as far as
are they guilty in any way that it
hasn't been that they haven't been
accused of not that I know of
but I say the investigations going on we
through the researchers I've worked with
or continuing this interest and we're
still looking we'd like to get all we
could so much of it is sealed away that
we can't touch
but I don't know of anything specific
from the individuals you mentioned
anything else yes ma'am actually the you
know that the maybe the the multi node
and theory about the assassination or
Phil Kennedy is the theory is he posted
by the Oliver Stone which is famous
movie famous movie so what the different
because it is about like a B or C about
the CIA they mark the other Cuba so what
is the the different with your book
beside you know the possibility of money
on your phone well let me explain
because you see there's not that big a
difference Oliver Stone did come out
with a movie that was critical to
keeping the investigation going to set
it up the assassination records Review
Board
he never named any one group as you
mentioned there were several but he did
not exclude Lyndon Johnson what I'm
bringing in is how Lyndon Johnson had
this interest and when I mentioned
earlier Edward Clark made sure he had
support he talked to and we've been able
to track it both the Dallas and Houston
to make sure that he had to support a
big oil and through big oil because a
lot of people don't know this but a lot
of their money went into the military
industrial complex and through Brown &
Root so you had these major economic
interests that were aware that something
was going to happen but Clark kept the
assassination very very close
in other words very few people that were
involved and really knew about it what
he did was what he's done for years and
years and that's give what's called
insider information and the more vague
he made it the more that the bigger it
was his friends knew that and he
couldn't tell him some things because
they had to have what's called credible
deniability in other words if crimes or
were charged he couldn't tell them what
i recommended you buy some of Texas
eastern natural gas pipeline because
it's going to go really really going to
go up but these things were going on it
was insiders approach and Clark was so
trusted by these men and what they were
really feeding on is not so much some
specifics like the Vietnam War
but a general unhappiness with the way
Kennedy was trying to build peace and
work some sort of a living living
relationship with the Soviet Union they
did not want this to happen
I mentioned Edwin Walker earlier he was
one person that went over the wall so to
speak overlord on it there were others
and it was this deep-seated feeling that
a lot of people had and they were very
powerful people they didn't want John
Kennedy around they did not like the way
he was taking the country section Okita
Nader possible of the angel and junk
immediate the best explanation I can
give it is that there was this bonfire
ready to go off and Johnson became the
spark because of the deep problems he
was facing both and not having any power
and being threatened with imprisonment
and when he could talk to Clark and get
Clark to go to work to make sure that
what would be done would be okay without
giving out any details
it happened it's I try and bring that
out in the book to this almost subtle
world that exists among these men with
great power where I don't say here's
what we're doing blah blah blah and lay
it out 1 2 3 but they know you know
something is going to happen and it does
yes
started riffing in a book about a fact
that rorn did not take Jack for me to
Washington to testify otherwise with
your opinion of Warren was told not to
take everybody come to Washington or cut
up to some city light on that in your
book I mentioned that very briefly but
the only thing Earl Warren was and I
think a respected jurist but why he
didn't do more as beyond me part of it
was that other members of the Commission
were pretty much set in one way and he
probably could have made any change
there he went to see the Ruby polygraph
exam and Ruby failed it and yet Earl
Warren did nothing to follow up with
what you were just talking about I don't
go into that very deeply but I do
mention that most members of the Warren
Commission over the years agreed they
had not done a good job and wish they'd
done a much better job
and Earl Warren I I think it was his
words himself that it was the biggest
disappointment in my career yes why why
were the oilmen Post Kennedy they have
hoped him deeply because really three
things the depletion allowance imports
and federal regulation of natural gas
prices I guess that's where I
specifically came in as an expert but
this was a fight that Johnson picked up
in 1949 when he came into the Senate and
became the oil businesses lobbyist on
the floor of the Senate the Senate knew
that if they want to do anything with
depletion allowance imports or natural
gas they had to go through Johnson and
it was a bitter fight Johnson was one
though by keeping them from having any
of these changes made that were trying
to be made that turned to oil
multimillionaires into billionaires in
the 60s I'm trying to said you worked as
a lawyer in Texas and I guess you were
representing these same interests in
soil interests and he I was since what I
alluded to a little bit earlier I
represented a snake oil which had a
really big case going and we managed to
lift the lid on natural gas prices the
value of the company went from $8 a
share in two months to something like
160 dollars a share it was that kind of
a change shortly after that federal
Power Commission pretty well pull back
from regulation set a national rate and
then it disappeared but Aztecas was
owned by Wofford Kane who was a founding
member of big oil grew up in Athens
Texas with Clint Murchison they were
dear friends and through him and his
officers I learned a lot about these
connections that existed
so you move from working for Big Oil to
try to expose this well it became a
necessity yes I I had a falling out with
my partners they wanted me to represent
a company lavaca that was stealing left
and right where I'd been representing
most of the other companies in Texas
against them they asked me three
different times in the course of about
an hour to sign this document and I
refused namely at a conflict and I
wasn't about to and that's when they
took it to Clark and he sent the word
back to me that this is something Leon
Jaworski wants and whatever he wants he
gets and I still didn't sign and I left
the firm shortly after that so I was I'm
Howard of in about 1976
I have to equivocate a little because
when I left the law firm I left
everything I thought it was protected by
the privilege and I couldn't touch this
information when they sued me though and
I got into a fight with one of their
banks I said forget it
this is a corrupt system I don't have to
put up with this anymore I then look
into the privilege itself the privilege
is very broad it says that attorney
can't tell what happens unless necessary
to prevent imminent injury I think
that's wrong I think there is no
protection for lawyers to commit crimes
and I don't have any trouble bringing it
out the final thing
well now your sons are working for an
administration that's beholden to big
oil how do you feel about that I have no
information about what's going on now if
I were the lawyer for the president I
might know more there was you know
that's in fact the case well I really
don't because I don't have the comfort
of being there and knowing what's really
being said by the lawyers and I don't
know any way I'd ever found out but as a
lawyer these are the Edward Clark was
what was called by a Washington writer
super lawyer and these guys know what's
going on and and they're the ones I
think you'd have to ask that question I
can't tell you what's going on now most
of these men that were really ruthless
have disappeared from the scene and I
guess the safest comment is when my son
makes I just can't make a comment on me
the more assertive than any writer I've
read about Johnson and his claim that he
was never a religious man and you said
that he was he would have a refrain if I
can't touch it it ain't real and then
you're claiming that he really at times
believed he was God himself but but you
said in in his last days that he did get
some religion or and then that that was
a part of the torment that he was in for
yes here we ever that's right he when he
left the presidency he was a broken man
and deep depression brought on by his
paranoia ladybird that's when he and
ladybird really became close and she
tried to help him and private
psychiatrist was brought in and did in
fact help him get rid of his demons and
prepare him to meet his maker so he did
get religion then but when he referred
to himself as hell boys don't you know I
am God he was not taking any Supreme
Being with any respect except himself
the information Eugene Hill breeding or
Jim breeding
I've seen it I don't have enough to say
what he was doing some people think you
know and still believe that but I don't
have any information on him
any other questions thank you very much